let's talk about today with what's going
on with ukraine and russia okay on one
end
biden's talking about the fact that
you know russia is going to attack
ukraine russia is going to attack
ukraine russia is going to attack
ukraine ukraine prime minister is like
stop saying that you're scaring the hell
out of my people what does it matter
with you on a call to biden okay
so yeah
when i saw that going on the first
person i thought about was you
i'm not kidding with you first person i
thought about was you yeah i'm thinking
of going to ukraine actually okay so
then maybe you're going there to do some
business which
so first person i thought about was you
i said i said
i said i wonder how
john reads this story the day-to-day guy
reads the story saying oh my gosh
russia is going to go in there and take
whatever they want from ukraine and it's
going to suck and
but and then you know maybe somebody
that's a little bit more educated that's
complete something else maybe somebody
else that's a little bit more educated
and follows news a little bit more and
knows you know well you know here's
what's really going on over there and
you know maybe somebody that's a little
bit skeptical with uh you know biden
talking about the fact that he had
dealings with ukraine and he's made
money from ukraine and the big guy and
all that other stuff i said i wonder
what how john looks at this because i
know john politically which way you lean
i know which way you're politically but
i also know as much as whatever side i
lean politically left right center
registered independent
i still still sit there and say
huh
would uh would trump have contacted
russia to help him with the election
what chances do i think that would
happen
that's pretty interesting because
everyone's talking about it now
and this atom guy shift made it there is
certain you know no question about it
there's evidence that there was
collusion with russia like oh [ __ ] he
just said it damn
and then this and this and that
and then the dossier came out it was set
up by hillary clinton 35 million bucks
and then durham comes back with the
investigation mueller spent 40 million
this guy only needed 3 million oh [ __ ]
it was all hillary the entire time
she's the mastermind behind it
what a freaking dirty way of doing it so
you do to the other person and you tell
the world that that person is doing what
you're doing to them they're doing it to
you you really are a con man at the
highest level so from your end
give us all potential scenarios of
what's going on with ukraine russia
let's see if you're going to be open
about it
instead of maybe being selective and
just giving us the side that you want to
give us how do you think is going on
there
i just came from nassau in the bahamas
where i was teaching a course nasa was
the pirate capital of the world at one
time pirate republic
but you know the pirates never um they
didn't want to attack other ships
particularly why they had that big flag
with the skeleton crossbones just
scared the [ __ ] out of
the ships that were coming up and and
and most of the ships knew that if they
just gave up
uh they would have to lose you know
whatever the pirates wanted that was on
their ship but nobody would be killed
it was the flag the flag the fear the
pirates would appear on the deck
semi-naked or maybe naked looking very
fierce and so on
i think russia is doing that on ukraine
i think russia is standing on the edge
of ukraine uh waving that that that
jolly roger skull and crossbone flag
and it's trying to negotiate it wants to
it does not want um ukraine to become
part of nato
it's trying desperately to bring people
it's been very successful incidentally
and now you know the the heads of many
countries are talking to putin they
wouldn't have before so in a way they're
getting their way in terms of getting
everybody to talk to them the united
states is getting all upset and involved
in it
and that certainly biden is wanting to
look very strong it's a it's an election
year and he's he's wanting to look
strong so he's he's making it sound as
though russia is absolutely going to
attack ukraine who knows but i don't i
was
speaking at a at a conference in russia
in 2017
along with putin we were both speaking
at the conference i got to know his
his uh
top economic adviser sergey glasgow very
well he and i flew to kazakhstan
together and spoke there
um you know that the sense i got is that
that putin is a very shrewd operator
he's very very clever
and he knows the world pretty well
and so he's trying to get whatever he
can out of this he's using the leverage
of his troops on the border to get
talked with all kinds of people to get
recognized he loves he loves to be on
the front page he's getting on the front
page a lot will he actually attack
ukraine or not i i have no idea
but i do know that i that we are
the united states and many other
countries are feeding into his hands
you don't think there's anything else
going on there that's politics behind
closed doors that we don't know oh
there's lots of stories behind the
stories for sure
i mean any potential like what if what
if it could be maybe this it could be
this it could be that what are some
things you would speculate if somebody
hired you to investigate this
well i think it could be
part part of it is uh that that putin is
trying very hard to win friends with
china he sees that china is going to
probably
control a third of the world's economy
in the next 10 years that's the way it's
headed
russia is a country that's kind of left
out at the moment you've got
china and the united states are center
stage right now they're they're they're
duking it out so to speak
and russia's left on the outside so
putin's struggling very hard to get back
in there
so you think that's the only thing you
think the only thing is the fact that
putin is trying to get back in there so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]